[Applaus]
[Musik]
weißrussland ist das perfekte Beispiel
für ein Land das die Machtstrukturen des
gefallenen kommunistischen Imperiums nie
hinter sich gelassen hat Belarus ist
eine ehemalige Sowjetrepublik die
eigentlich Klischees eines typischen
hollywoodfilms über eine solche
entspricht eine relativ armes Land das
von einem bizarren Tyrannen mit eisernen
Faust regiert wird und es sind nicht nur
wie ihr die ihn als Tyrannen bezeichnen
ich möchte euch daran erinnern dass er
sich selbst damit berühmt ein
autoritärer Regierungsstil ist
charakteristisch für mich und ich habe
das immer zugegeben es ist besser
Diktator zu sein als schwul Alexander
Lukaschenka Präsident von Belarus wir
sprechen hier von einem Diktator der
angesichts der inflationskrise die die
Welt erlebt die perfekte Lösung gefunden
hat die Inflation einfach per Gesetz zu
verbieten nein das ist kein Scherz hört
es euch selbst an Inflation in
Weißrussland verboten Weißrussland
verbietet verbraucherpreiserhöhungen um
die Inflation einzudämmen ich werde in
diesem Video nicht darauf eingehen warum
der Versuch Inflation einfach zu
verbieten aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht ein
Kur Fehler ist diese Diskussion werden
wir auf visualökonomic unserem neuen
wirtschaftskanal führen wenn ihr noch
nicht kennt dann schaut doch mal rein
den Link dazu findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video aber
natürlich ist das Verbot der Inflation
nicht die einzige Maßnahme mit der
dieser Tyrann versucht die
Preissteigerungen einzudämmen habt ihr
schon mal was von der allgemeinen
Mobilisierung für die Kartoffelernte
gehört ja so etwas gibt es in Belarus
tatsächlich guck mal
Weißrussland Kinder sollen Kartoffeln
und Äpfel ernten sagt lukaschenker nun
ja er begann mit echten Kindern und
erklärte das schließlich das halbe Land
zu solchen
aber keine Angst die Kartoffelernte ist
nicht der Grund warum weiß aus landet in
diesem Video die Hauptrolle spielt die
Wahrheit ist nun mal dass lukaschen
letzter Zeit nicht primär mit seiner
eigenartigen Wirtschaftspolitik
internationale Aufmerksamkeit erregt hat
nein er steht im Rampenlicht weil es
sein Land ist dass sie schrecklichen
russische Invasion in der Ukraine am
meisten unterstützt und es gibt sogar
Spekulation dass ich weiß Russland im
Überfall gegen seinen südlichen Nachbarn
anschließen nutzen könnte so verkündet
die Regierung des selbsternannten
letzten Diktator Europas im Juni die
Gründung des Einsatzkommandos Süd einer
Kampftruppe die an der Grenze zu Ukraine
stationiert werden soll außerdem
kündigte sie den Ausbau der Armee an
bestätigte Anfang Oktober das eine
gemeinsames militärkontingent mit
Russland aufgestellt werden soll und
siehe da Anfang November wurde durch
Satellitenaufnahmen bestätigt dass ein
drei Orten bereits ganze Zeit Städte
errichtet wurden in denen sich bis zu
7.500 russische Soldaten finden können
und da ist die Unterbringung in anderen
Gebäudearten noch nicht berücksichtigt
das könnte bedeuten dass das bis zu
20.000 Soldaten aus dem Land der Zahlen
in Belarus stationiert worden sind zur
Erinnerung als im Februar die Invasion
losgehen viel von Belarus aus ca 30 000
großen Krieger in die Ukraine ein Putin
scheint also gar nicht mehr so weit von
der Auffrischung seines ursprünglichen
Nordost Kontingenz entfernt zu sein
zumindest zahlenmäßig aber nach Angaben
des lukasche wurde diese Entscheidung
natürlich nur getroffen um seine Grenzen
zu schützen wir betonen noch einmal dass
die Aufgaben der regionalen
streitkräftegruppe rein wichtig sind und
alle Aktivitäten die derzeit
durchgeführt werden ziehen darauf ab ein
ausreichende Antwort auf Aktionen in der
Nähe unserer Grenze zu geben Viktor
Training in weißrussischer
Verteidigungsminister nun ja natürlich
hat ihnen das niemand abgekauft der
ukraine-spräsidentin ist bei der
nächsten G7 Sitzung die Alarmglocken
stellen und schlug vor Teams der UN an
die ukrainische weißrussische Grenze zu
schicken um eine neue Eskalation des
Konflikts zu verhindern an der Grenze
zwischen der Ukraine und Weißrussland
können wir eine Mission internationaler
Beobachter platzieren um die
Sicherheitslage zu überwachen das Format
kann von unseren Diplomaten
ausgearbeitet werden ich bitte Sie auf
der Ebene der G7 diese Initiative zu
unterstützen wo Leute die mir sehr
selinski Präsident der Ukraine nun ja
das wird natürlich nicht passieren denn
wie wir alle wissen Tauben die Vereinten
Nation Jesus von Gesten und Erklärung
nicht sonderlich viel wenn es hart auf
hart kommt selenski lässt sich daher
lieber auf harte Fakten besser gesagt
auch Stahlbeton hatte
die Ukraine baut entlang der Grenze zu
Bela muss eine 1.000 km lange Mauer um
sich von seinem nördlichen Nachbarn
bestmöglich und endgültig abzuschotten
denn niemand wirklich niemand traut mehr
solchen Potentaten wie Luca Schenker
über den Weg vor allem wenn es immer
wieder zu verdächtigen militärischen
Bewegungen in Russland und Weißrussland
kommt gleichzeitig sind die Russen in
der Ukraine nicht nur in die Defensive
geraten sondern geradezu Zwang denn egal
wie weit hinter die freut sich ihre
logistiklinien verlegen die Ukraine
schafft es immer wieder diese an einem
von Abschnitt nach dem anderen zu
zerstören und damit die russischen
Truppen der Auslosung preiszugeben
möglich macht dies die tödliche
Kombination aus minusius das Satelliten
Aufklärung ihrer mittlerweile
zementierten präzisions Artillerie
Übermacht und ihre den großen weit
überlegenen taktischen Fähigkeit
und während die ersten beiden Faktoren
ohne westliche Hilfe nicht möglich
gewesen wären beruht der letzte auf der
grandiosen Moral und Genialität der
ukrainischen Armeeführung des
offiziers-kurs und der gut ausgebildeten
und mutigen Soldaten man kann kaum noch
mit die vielen erfolgreichen Strategien
Taktiken und Manöver der Ukrainer
mitzuzählen die in die geschichts- und
Militär Lehrbücher eingehen werden und
nach dem verlorenen Schlachten um Kiew
und zuletzt Restaurant weiß Putin
mittlerweile gut dass die ukrainische
Streitkräfte seinen Verbänden immer
mindestens einen Schritt voraus sein
werden er weiß dass sie durchgeschickte
Aufklärung ultimierung Ablenkung und
schließlich Fokussierung einen
Frontabschnitt nach dem anderen
durchbrechen und für sich entscheiden
werden und daher steht er unter großen
Zugzwang was soll er also tun er wird
auf die Schnelle weder seine Generäle
und Offiziere klüger machen noch
irgendeine wunderbare aus dem zaubern
können beim Thema taktische Atomwaffen
hat ihm ja sein oberkörperchen erst
kürzlich massiv auf die Finger gehauen
und zwar auch wenn es nur um verbale
Drohungen damit geht welche Joker
bleiben Putin also angesichts dieser
rechts versteckten Situation drängt sich
natürlich die Frage auf inwieweit Plan
Putin weiß Russland in seinem Krieg
hineinzuziehen wäre dies vielleicht der
Joker das Krieg wieder zu meine Gunsten
wenden könnte schließlich ist die
Hauptstadt Kiew von Belarus aus
besonders leicht zu erreichen könnte er
hier einen letzten Befreiungsschlag
planen macht Putin Luca schenka zu
seinem Steine wozu genau wollen Belarus
und Russland ihre angekündigte
gemeinsame Armee einsetzen und was
könnte das für die ukrainische Armee
bedeuten in diesem Video werden wir all
diese Fragen beantworten bevor wir
jedoch total schreiben müssen wir noch
zwei kleine Dinge erledigen zum einen
müssen wir die Frage abhandeln warum um
alles in der Welt unterstützt
lukaschenker nach wie vor dem Mega loser
Putin wäre es nicht an der Zeit sich von
ihm genauso auch zu setzen wie es zum
Beispiel der kasachische Präsident hat
und zum anderen müssen wir kurz Werbung
machen für unseren tollen Sponsor
surfshark also auf geht's
ist ein wirklich empfehlenswertes und
sicheres VPN welches social keinerlei
Verbindungsdaten mit lockt natürlich
kann ein Virtual Private Networks VPN
einen nicht vor allem Gefahren man muss
nach wie vor um sich bald lassen und
wissen was man tut aber es stellt hier
für ein Werkzeug mit gleich mehreren
Vorteilen da zum einen erschwert ist in
Kombination mit anderen Vorkehrungen
eure Aktionen und abzuhören mit Hilfe
verschiedener Sicherheitsfeatures könnt
ihr so erhöhen z.B mit dem integrierten
klimap dass alle cookiesblockt weiterer
Vorteil als VPN ist dass ihr so tun
können als während ihr in einem anderen
Ort suchen Internet
verfügbar wäre noch daheim oder im
Urlaub damit schlagt jetzt sind nur und
blocking ein Schnäppchen Netflix und
anderes
anbieten von Europa oder deutsches
Internet fernsehen im Ausland gucken mit
kein Problem und das ist noch lange
nicht alles mit nur einem Konto könnt
ihr wirklich alle eure Endgeräte im VPN
registrieren Handys Notebooks oder sogar
bei uns Smart TV so und zum Black Friday
hat zwar ein besonderes Angebot für euch
auf Lager wenn ihr den Rabattcode weg.de
angeht bekommt ihr volksausschlag ein
Rabatt in Höhe von 85% und oben seine
ersten drei Monate gratis dazu greift
jetzt zu denn dieses Angebot ist
zeitlich limitiert den Link findet ihr
wie immer in der Beschreibung unter
diesem Video also nichts besonderes auch
gleichzeitig uns finanziert unter die
Arme das könnt ihr übrigens auch direkt
mit Hilfe des Spenden links den ich euch
ebenfalls in die Beschreibung gepackt
habe wir sind euch für jede
Unterstützung danke damit hättet ihr uns
euch in Zukunft noch mehr und noch
besser Videos zu liefern so und nun zu
unserer ersten Frage warum um alles in
der Welt steht lukaschenker noch immer
hinter Putin und lässt sich von diesem
in den Abgrund ziehen nun hört gut zu
denn er hat seine Gründe
vom allmachtsträumer zur [ __ ]
Alexander lukaschen
1994 in dieser Zeit hat sich sein Regime
von einer mehr oder weniger gemäßigten
autoritären Regierung in eine zunehmend
korrupt und repressive autokrative
handelt eine Diktatur die mehr als 1.300
politische Gefangenen und das Land in
ein Ödland politischer Alternativen
verwandelt hat obwohl das Regime
furchtbar und populär ist es überrascht
nicht das sind Zuge dessen auch die
Pressefreiheit ein Ende gefunden hat und
bei einem BIP von etwas mehr als 7000
US-Dollar pro Kopf einem der niedrigsten
in Europa unterstützen oder
sympatisieren schätzungen zufolge gerade
mal 25% der Bevölkerung mit der
Regierung sogar bei diesen Unterstützern
handelt es sich hauptsächlich um Rentner
Bürokraten und Personal der
Sicherheitskräfte aber was das Regime
nicht mit der Unterstützung des Volkes
erreicht erreicht es natürlich mit
Waffengewalt Knüppeln und Handschellen
in gewisser Weise ist diese politische
Situation also jener in Russland sehr
ähnlich aber Russland obwohl Putin und
Luca Schenker heute fast wie Blut Brüder
und unzertrennliche Verbündete
erscheinen haben sie sich in Wahrheit
nicht immer so gut verstanden
[Musik]
im Jahr 1999 unterzeichnete der
weißrussische Diktator ein Abkommen mit
dem russischen Präsidenten Bares yelze
um eine vollständige politische und
wirtschaftliche Union zwischen den
beiden Ländern zu schaffen die Idee
dahinter war eine super-nationale
Einheit zu schaffen die letztendlich für
die wirtschaftsaußen- und
Verteidigungspolitik zuständig sein
sollte es wurde sogar spekuliert dass
die Länder am Ende dieselbe Währung
gemeinsame Gerichte und sogar ein
gemeinsames Parlament haben könnten aber
das erstaunlicht an dieser ganzen
Geschichte ist dass der Billa russische
Staatschef scheinbar damals davon
ausgeht er selbst würde diese
mega-nation am Ende regieren mit anderen
Worten was Lukas Schenker vorsteht da
war eine Art Übernahmeangebot bei den
der kleine Fisch den großen schlucken
würde seine Idee war tatsächlich das
weiß gruseln am Ende ganz Russland
kontrolliert wurde
oder zumindest dass er persönlich beide
Staaten regieren würde doch mit der
Machtübernahme Putins in Moskau gegen
Luca Schenkers Pläne den Bach runter und
das weißrussische Übernahmeangebot wurde
auf den Kopf gestellt plötzlich wurde
der Deal zu einer Art Einfassung für
eine russische Annexion des Landes und
aus diesem Grund hat lukaschenker den
gesamten Prozess erstmal gestoppt und
nicht nur das nach der russischen
Annexion der Krim begann Weißrussland
Moskau auf Linie zu sein schienen in
Braten zu riechen na was glaubt ihr was
der letzte Diktator Europas damals getan
hat nun im Grunde wollte er mit Moskau
spielen indem er eng gerade Beziehungen
zum Westen knüpfte tatsächlich erkannte
er die Grimm nicht einmal als Teil der
Russlands an und die Beziehungen wurden
immer angespannter bis 2020
in jedem Jahr 2020 gab es eine Wahl in
Wähler aus einem manipulierte Wahl in
Oberschenkel natürlich mit 80% der
Stimmen gewann ihr wisst schon eine
lupenreiner und eindeutiger Sieg aber
dieses Mal sollte es nicht zu bleiben
die Empörung des Volkes über die
offensichtliche Wahlfälschung führte zu
massenaufständen die den Diktator
beinahe gestürzt hätten und ihr fragt
euch sicherlich was dann als nächstes
geschah nun Putin wurde so etwas wie
eine Rettungsanker für den
weißrussischen
Propagandisten sicherheitsteams Geld und
bestätigte schließlich sogar dass er
militärisch eingreifen würde mit anderen
Worten er würde Panzer schicken um
seinen neuen Diktatoren Freund gegen
sein eigenes Volk zu schützen aber
natürlich war all diese Unterstützung
nicht umsonst von diesem Moment an wurde
lukaschenker zu einer gehorsamen
Marionette moskauz und die Pläne für
eine schrittweise Integration der beiden
Länder wurden wieder aus der Schublade
herausgeholt aber warum in aller Welt
ist der Kreml eigentlich so ein Wähler
aus interessiert
[Musik]
nun russland versucht seit den 1990er
Jahren seine politischen
wirtschaftlichen und militärischen
Beziehungen zu Weißrussland auszubauen
diese Bemühungen haben jedoch seit 2020
deutlich an Bedeutung gewonnen und
hinter diesem großen Interesse Moskau
aus können wir drei Hauptgründe finden
die erklären warum dieses strategische
Thema von höchster Wichtigkeit für den
Channel ist erstens Weißrussland war
wichtig für die russische Wirtschaft
dann mehr als 20% aller russischen
Gasexporte nach Europa Durchfall
Russland liefern zweitens ist das Land
der kürzeste Weg um die Exklave
Kaliningrad auf dem Landweg zu erreichen
eine Stationierung russischer Truppen
Bilder aus würde es ermöglichen in einem
Krieg mit den besten Korridor
abzuschneiden denn eine Besetzung dieses
schmalen Streifens Landes an der
polnischen Grenze hätte wohl den
Durchmarsch von NATO-Truppen in die
baltischen Staaten verhindern können und
drittens wegen Putins eigener
Besessenheit das große russische Reich
wieder herzustellen und das ist im
Grunde dasselbe Motiv das in den Ukraine
getrieben hat
tja was gibt es für Putin besseres als
Mütterchen Russland zu vergrößern unser
neues Reich wieder zu historischer Größe
zu führen oder wie Wasserfarbe ist man
sagte das Problem Russland ist dass es
nicht weiß wo es anfängt und wo ist
aufhört ihr seht also wieder einmal auch
im Falle Weißrussland gilt es gibt keine
Zufälle
denn erschweren kam hinzu dass die
internationalen Sanktionen die
Abhängigkeit Weißrussland von seinem
großen Bruder vervielfacht haben und wie
ihr euch vorstellen könnt hatte Putin
kein Problem damit seine neuen Lakaien
mit großzügigen Krediten zu unterstützen
das erklärte dann warum wir nach dem
rücksichtslosen russischen einmal in der
Ukraine auf aussagen wie diese gestoßen
sind diejenigen die uns Vorwürfe machen
wussten sie nicht dass wir das engste
Bündnis mit der Russischen Föderation
haben mit ihnen bauen wir einen einzigen
mächtigen und abhängigen Staat auf den
Unionsstaat wir waren und werden mit dem
brüderlichen Russland zusammen sein
unsere Teilnahme an der spezialoperation
wurde von mir schon vor langer Zeit
beschlossen Alexander lukaschenke
Präsident von
genug hat der Diktator während des
gesamten Krieges einen akribischen
Balanceakt vorgeführt einerseits räumt
er ein das vor der Invasion 30.000
russische Soldaten in seinem Land
stationiert waren das waren die Truppen
die am 24 februar zum Sturm auf Kiew
plus geschickt wurden außerdem erlaubte
er Russland sein Land als Plattform für
den Abschluss einer massiven Zeile von
Raketen gegen die Ukraine zu nutzen
schon vier Tage nach dem Einmarsch
hubliker die verfassungsmäßige
Neutralität eines Landes auf und
erlaubte Russland damit ständige Truppen
sogar Atomwaffen in Belarus zu
stationieren erinnert ihr euch noch an
seine Spitznamen putinette nun ist wisst
ihr warum bei ihm trägt was Weißrussland
jedoch nicht tat war direkt in den Krieg
einzutreten und in letzter Zeit stellt
sich immer häufiger die Frage warum
Gerüchte aufkommen dass sich dies bald
ändern könnte bedeutet die Aufstellung
des gemeinsamen Militär Kontingents das
weiße Russland seine Position ändern und
aktiv in den Kampf eingreifen wird wenn
ja was genau würde dann auf die Ukraine
zu kommen und das schauen wir uns jetzt
im Detail an
[Musik]
während des Kalten Kriegs war das Gebiet
Weißrussland sehr wichtig für die
Sowjetunion die in der sogenannten
weißrussischen sozialistischen Sowjet
republikationierten Truppen waren als
die Speerspitze des Backshops im Falle
eines Konflikts mit dem Westen gedacht
deshalb befand sich ein großer Teil der
modernsten militärischen ausrüstungs
darunter ein Viertel aller sowjetischen
Hintergrund
jedoch völlig heute ist die
belarussische Armee lächerlich klein und
furchtbar veraltet fast ihre gesamte
Ausrüstung ist seit Jahrzehnten im
Dienst und stand noch aus bestimmten der
Sowjet Armee tatsächlich ist Belarus
eines der wenigen Länder das mehr für
die innere Sicherheit ausgibt als für
seine Streitkräfte mit anderen Worten
wir sprechen weniger von einer
militärikatur sondern vor allem von
einem Polizeistaat genau dort hat das
Regime fast alle seine Ressourcen
konzentriert inzwischen macht der
Militärhaushalt kommt noch ein Prozent
des Pep aus etwas 700 Millionen Dollar
jährlich obwohl er in den letzten Jahren
gestiegen ist und das ist noch nicht
alles was das gesamte Geld dient nur zur
Deckung laufender kosten die Investition
in den Kauf von Waffen und militärische
Ausrüstung sind verschwindend gering
zwischen 2014 und 2019 hat das Land
gerade mal 898 Millionen Dollar in
diesem Bereich ausgegeben das ist ein
jährlicher Durchschnitt von gerade mal
180 Millionen Dollar und davon müssen
wir noch die Abzweigungen korrupter
Politiker Beamter und Militärs abziehen
dieser eklatante Mangel an finanziellen
Mitteln erklärt dann auch warum die
belarussische Armee nur aus etwa 50.000
Soldaten besteht und es kommt noch
schlimmer von diesem Truppen sind
derzeit bloß 17.000 Mann ausgebildet und
einsatzbereit und das ist noch eine
große geschäftung viele Quellen
reduzieren sie sogar noch weiter auf
eine Spanne zwischen 6000 und 10.000
Soldaten erschweren kommt hinzu das weiß
Russland seit dem Ausbruch des Krieges
eine große Menge militärischen Materials
an Russland geliefert hat wir haben
weder die Truppen doch das militärische
Gerät ein Großteil der Ausrüstung wurde
bereits an die Russische Föderation
übergeben es gibt nur wenige
kampfbereite Truppen bis zu 7000 und
diese nicht bereit für ein anderes
Operation
aber der Mangel an Truppen ist nicht die
einzige auffällige Tatsache so verfügt
die Luft war verschätzungen zufolge nur
24 Kampf gegen Flugzeug und ja nee kann
auch etwa 200 altes sowjetische t72
Panzer erzählen
als Abschreckung besitzt Belarus
immerhin angeblich mehr als 290.000
Reservisten aber in Wahrheit schaut es
niemanden zu interessieren dass diese
über minimale Ausrüstung der Ausbildung
Verfügung und in einem Krieg wohl kaum
von großen Nutzen werden lukaschen
Diktatur hat zugegebenermaßen eine große
Menge altes materialauflage aber es
bleibt abzuwarten in welchen Zustand
sich dieses überhaupt befindet denn
nachdem wir das russische disaster in
der Ukraine gesehen haben ist wieder von
Weißrussland noch von dem
neustationierten russischen Verbänden
viel Zucker dabei und zwar werden auch
sozialen Medien immer wieder Videos
verbreitet die angeblich russische
Panzer Schützenpanzer und Haubitzen mit
bedrohlich wirkenden neuen taktischen
Markierungen in Weißrussland zeigen aber
dabei handelt es sich in Wahrheit Umzüge
der belarussischen Armee
[Musik]
diese weißrussischen Truppen verstärken
jedoch nicht die Stellungen an der
Grenze zu Ukraine es handelt sich
lediglich um eine Rotation die Brigaden
in den letzten Monaten die Grenze
verstärkt haben kehren zu ihren
Stützpunkt zurück und werden durch neue
ersetzt die Gesamtzahl der drucken
bleibt dabei gleich und es
Satellitenfotos nahezu urteilen handelt
es sich auch bei den gesichteten
russischen Truppen um keine regulären
Armeeeinheiten die in Weißrussland
eintreffen sondern nur um frisch
mobilisierte russische Reservisten mit
entsprechend weniger Erfahrung russische
militärflüge transportieren derzeit kein
schweres Gerät mehr nach Belarus sondern
nur Lastwagen Tankwagen und Soldaten
diese werden nicht wie im Januar an die
Grenze zu Ukraine gebracht sondern zu
Ausbildungsstätten im Norden
Weißrussland damit sie nicht von der
mittlerweile Überlebenden ukrainischen
Artillerie sofort zu Gulasch verarbeitet
werden können mit anderen Worten in
diesem Stadium geht es mit ziemlicher
Sicherheit um die Ausbildung russische
Reservisten in Weißrussland da alle
russischen Ausbildungslager und
Schießstände überlastet sind Moskau
lagert also das Training der mobics aus
Kapazitätsgründen nach Belarus aus und
mit diesen Truppen eine erneute Invasion
auf Tier zu starten wäre eine noch
größere Cloud Fiesta als das erste Mal
die weißrussische ukrainische Grenze ist
fast vollständig von unpassierbaren
Sünden bedeckt die dortige Region
polesien genannt ist schließlich das
größte Feuchtgebiet Europas die wenigen
Abschnitte entlang der Straßen über die
die Russen im Februar Angriffen wurden
von den Ukrainern mittlerweile in so
etwas wie eine neue Maschine Linie
verwandelt mit Minenfeldern gestaltete
Verteidigung sprengten Brücken und so
weiter ein Angriff der weißrussischen
Gruppierung in ihrem jetzigen Zustand an
dieser Front wäre militärisches selbst
wahrscheinlich auch den politischen
selbstportruckers darstellen würde aber
Moment mal wenn dem so ist warum wird
dann so viel über Weißrussland
gesprochen warum all die Gerüchte und
das Leben Rasseln das Moskau und
mindestens in letzter Zeit spielen nun
auch hier können wir drei mögliche
Antworten finden zunächst einmal könnten
die russischen und weißrussischen
Soldaten die erneut an der Grenze keine
stationiert werden das Ziel haben einen
Teil seiner Truppen in dieses Gebiet zu
verlegen um eine erneuten Angriff vom
Norden zu verhindern das könnte den
enormen Druck unter dem großen und Süden
der Ukraine etwas verringern in den
dortigen Gebieten das Ziel die
ukrainischen Truppen die ihr wisst ja
momentan größere Gelände gewinnen einige
vermuten sogar das Moskau sollte sich
die Lage weiter verschlechtern einen
neuen Angriff auf Kiew fragen könnte
nicht weil sie denken sie könnten die
bestens befestigte Hauptstadt diesmal
annehmen sondern nur wieder um
Zerstörung und Terror zu verbreiten egal
wie viele eigene Truppen dabei
draufgehen es ginge darum die
Bevölkerung der Ukraine einzuschüchtern
und Verhandlungen zu erzwingen oder die
Moral der ukrainischen Streitkräfte
sozusagen
mehr seine eigenen Einheiten an die
Front schicken kann während des
spielerische Staatsgebiet zum Abschluss
von Raketen nutzt und drittens könnte
genau das Gegenteil der Fall sein dass
all diese Ankündigungen einfach nur
darin müssen dass Weißrussland
herumstehendes mit der Gerät anrichten
Russland spendet in der Tat derzeit viel
Ausrüstung aus weißrussischen Lagern an
die Front gebracht darunter Panzer und
tonnenweise Munition was mit einer
angestritten militärischen Mobilisierung
im Land unvereinbar erscheint die
militärische Führer versuchen die
Truppen zu beruhigen indem sie sagen
dass sie nicht in den Krieg verwickelt
werden da die Soldaten besorgt sind wenn
sie den Erfolg der Ukraine sehen keiner
will für Putin kämpfen Frauenarzt
Wirtschaft Berater der Belarus
Oppositionsführerin Seat Lana
sicherungsgeier tatsächlich könnte der
Eintritt von Belarus in den Krieg sogar
kontraproduktiv für Russland sein warum
und zum einen weil es dazu führen könnte
das Washington der Ukraine Raketen mit
höhere Reichweite für die Heimat liefert
zum anderen könnte es auch Luca Schenker
in die Enge treiben
ihr müsst bedenken dass der Krieg in
Weißrussland äußerst unpopulär ist
Umfragen zufolge unterstützen weniger
als 10% der Bevölkerung die Teilnahme
ankriegt tatsächlich kann er schon
mehrfach Sabotage Akten gegen die
russische Armee Hinweis Russland und
selbst hochrangige Beamte wieder
stellvertretende Verteidigungsminister
sind aus Protest gegen die Unterstützung
der russischen Invasion zurückgetreten
natürlich hat Putin großen Einfluss aber
er kann sogar nicht dazu zwingen
politischen Selbstmord zu begehen Aktion
schreibt man weißrussischer Politik ist
wie ihr seht hat Weißrussland außer
veraltete Ausrüstung wenig beizutragen
und der kann schon sagen in welchen
Zustand sich diese heute befindet doch
wenn dieser Krieg durch etwas
gekennzeichnet ist dann ist es
moskausange eine Rationalität und wer
weiß vielleicht werden seine Kumpane
davon angesteckt aber wie dem auch sei
klar ist dass das lukaschen an diese
unmenschlichen grausamen Bälle von
Gewalt und Terror eine gewaltige
Mitschuld trinkt und deshalb muss seine
Regie ebenso wie die Russische
Föderation das Ziel internationaler
verurteile und Sanktionen sein aber
jetzt seit erstmal ihr an der Reihe
glaubt ihr das weiß wo sind will doch
irgendwann aus irgendeinem Grund den
Krieg erklären wird ist Luca schenka die
vorletzte Kugel in Moskau aus Magazin um
die Niederlage die es erlitten hat
vielleicht doch noch abzuwenden wie wird
sich dieser Konflikt eurer Meinung nach
entwickeln nun wie immer sind wir auf
eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon
mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass euch
dieses Video gefallen hat mir vielleicht
auch das bald gelernt habt falls ja gebt
uns bitte ein Like da sind Freunde noch
keines unserer Videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich freuen uns jederzeit über die
Spende von euch dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]